Good morning. Yeah. Um,
well I think it is high time that you
start thinking about your final paper.
And let me just one more time,
uh,
value what my expectation is a right,
there are three major blocks in
the course for each of the blocks.
That is a test you have done.
I have one more we'll be
done last week of classes.
Um,
um,
I mean the idea of the paper is
that you do a little more ambitious,
very crowds. You link, um, uh,
two of the blocks to it, to
each other. So you compare,
uh,
harps,
theory of human nature with the Durkheim's
theory of human nature or Harps Russo
and Durkheim or something
like this. Um, or, um,
uh,
you look at the vision of power in Hops,
Snitcher and vapor, right? Uh,
do two or three orders as such. Um, uh,
I also highly recommend you that you,
um,
uh, goal. What excites you the
most? Uh, you pick a topic,
what you find exciting.
If there was anything in this course,
what made you excited, right about
it, right? And you can use, uh,
uh, earlier, uh, asset
topics. What you brought up,
that's no problem. Uh, that there'll be
a new paper. Anyway, I had the class,
you have to link occasionally by distant
Otros to each other and talk to your
discussion section leader or send
an email. It can be very short, uh,
just to make sure that you
are on the right, um, uh, uh,
right trajectory, right? And probably
your discussion section leader of you.
I'll give you just a two
sentence response to say, yes,
this seems to be fine or no,
you are taking on too many at the law.
Too many orders. Why don't you do
only two or three rather than five,
what you suggested or avail, uh, you know,
you should be a little more ambitious,
right?
This is the kind of feedback
you should expect and advise.
And let me also say that one
more time. Uh, uh, you know,
was in discourse.
Uh,
we want to make this abstract
dude is relevant to your life.
So therefore don't shy
away if you have opinions,
if you can reflect how,
uh, the course, uh, um, uh,
helped or did not help to understand
yourself in society. Do so. Right.
Um, uh, but I think you really should, uh,
a doctor, your discussion section
leader or email at least on email,
um, uh, before you leave for
the vacation because, um, uh,
I want van the you,
you were out of tired of Turkey or you
had enough a beer and watching a football
and then you want to have fun,
then you can start working
on your final paper, right?
You don't leave it to the very end,
right?
But you can use your spare time during
Thanksgiving break to get started on it.
And that's not a big deal. You know, we
want you to do something like six store,
uh, more state beaches,
but more like six pages.
This is not really much more than,
you know,
the usual tests and assays. Okay. Um,
is that all clear and
the question about this?
No.
Anyway,
maybe we'll try to be as on
bureaucratic about this as a,
in a bureaucratic organization,
you can be all right.
As you have seen in this course,
we've trying to break the
rules of bureaucracy and
hopefully not at the expense
of efficiency or,
right.
So this is labor on the
labor theory on class and um,
Liz is probably neighbor next to Mark's
is the most influential theory of class,
um, uh, and the ad or saw on a
collision course with each other.
Uh, correlation of course
in many ways, uh, uh,
Ivy will elaborate on this,
but just to foreshadow, uh, uh,
uh,
that are really cool fun theory,
fundamentally important
issues where Markson Vapor,
these Agri marks,
as you recall,
identified classes in
property relationship I had,
the class I caught on me was between
those who own capital and those who own
only their labor power.
Vi Bird in contrast defines classes on
the marketplace as Marcus situations.
So the relationship, uh, this
would be more complicated,
but then the class relationship is
between the employer and the employee.
It is between the manager and the
worker and not the owner. Right.
And, uh, uh, the possessor
of labor power. Then march,
also sad of l a or
history of human Candice,
history of class struggles.
So vapor has a of Marx
has a theory of class,
which is overarching
the whole human history.
The is very specific about this
class is a modern phenomenon.
Classes only emerged with the
emergence of the market economy.
Market capitalism before
capitalism that are,
they are not the stratification
system is not based on class,
but it is based on status
and talking about, uh,
the notion of staters and grade there.
And finally that is obscured,
important political difference.
Marx believed that the class struggle
gets more intense over time and therefore
the subordinated class, eventually
you'll revolt and overthrow capitalism.
They were believed, uh, that
uh, the in the opposite, uh,
a class struggle is the most
intense in early stages,
rough stages of capitalism.
And as capitalism becomes
consolidated and bureaucratized,
class struggle is the actually reduced.
Um,
so these are the three
fundamental differences.
And this is the outline of the
presentation, uh, today. Uh,
so first of all I want to talk about
the usual interpretation of vapor and I
want to challenge these interpretation.
Uh,
if you ever took a course in which
Weber's theory of class was discussed,
you usually had the interpretation.
What I pleasant. Now,
if you go on the Internet and you
find what vapor got about class,
this is what you get. I
disagree with it. Um, and, uh,
IVL tried to show you why
this is the wrong approach.
Uh,
the usual interpretation goes back
to a British sociologists that,
uh, um, uh, Runciman who wrote
about this or that in the 1960s,
um, uh, uh, he's still
active actually. And, uh,
he interpreted the Labor as a offering,
a theory of social inequality.
Uh, in three dementia.
It's, uh, again, go on the Internet,
90% of,
uh,
Internet posting on vapor and the Class
V or give you this view what our dose
three dimensions,
status or prestige is one dimension.
The second is class, uh, usually
defined by income or avails.
And the third dimension is power.
Um,
and therefore,
if you look at stratification in society,
people can be unequal
in any of these, uh, uh,
can be privileged in any
of these dimensions or all
of the dimensions as such.
Uh, these, uh, Runciman, uh, uh, uh,
conceptualization of Weber's theory
of class was extremely influential on
empirical research. There was a lot of
empirical survey research carried out,
which was trying to measure,
uh,
how people fare in these three dimensions.
Um,
Gerhard Lenski,
uh,
who was professor and love and marriage
was professor was professor at the
University of North Carolina,
uh,
created a theory of status inconsistency.
Um,
the idea of was that, uh, um, uh,
people actually can be high in one,
one of these dimensions and
relatively low in another dimension.
So for instance, uh, uh, you
are a professor of sociology,
uh, then, you know, you were
prestige is a sort of reasonable,
you know, probably somewhat
higher than average. Um,
if you are a professor that,
you know,
it's a sort of even a little higher
than average, you know, uh, um,
substantially higher don't have rich.
Now in terms of intercom, you know,
if you are a professor of sociology,
you will,
will be again only slightly
higher than average of,
you'll not be very high
in terms of power hour.
You'll have, you'll be very
low in the power hierarchy. Um,
at least in the United
States, right? Nobody listens.
What sociologists are saying,
you know,
students who have to write
and occasionally they have
to take a sociology course.
That's the only power,
the Yali and professor exercises.
Now,
if you are a Supreme Court justice,
uh,
then your prestige is extremely high.
You are on the top of the pastiche
hierarchy, at least in the United States.
If you are asking who,
what,
who is the most prestigious occupation
in the United States in surveys,
people voc to be a supreme court justice,
right?
Serve on the Supreme Court.
Now, um, in terms of Entercom,
the Supreme Court justices
probably don't do all that well.
They probably do about as
university professors do. Uh, right.
Um, people in public service
usually don't do all that well.
I think probably a governor of a state
is not your anymore than a university
professor, but in terms of power, uh,
David would be very high,
right?
Supreme Court justices are very high or
occasionally they can even at poet tried
to president of the United States
if I may flag this joke. All right.
Anyway, they are very powerful. Well,
if you think about a mafioso,
the prestige of a godfather except
in the mafia will be very low,
right? You regard it as
criminal. Um, in terms of income,
you'll be on the very top,
right? In terms of power, well,
we will have some power, but mainly
in the mafia, not really nationally.
You see what they are getting get.
So therefore you cannot measure, uh,
uh, seizures, class and
power three dimensions.
And this is very helpful to
understand. Vetter, uh, uh, uh,
uh, the social status is crystallized, uh,
people who have high best.
These also have high incomes
and high power. And, uh, uh,
let's say somebody who is sleeping
on the floor, right? Um, uh,
uh, uh, we'll have very low prestige,
very low income and low power at all.
So that is a useful way how
to stratify society for upper,
upper class to lower lower class.
That is the way how vapor
usually it has been used.
Now I veal challenge this, uh, uh, uh,
uh, I don't think I'm the
only one who does challenges.
Anthony Giddens I think gets very
close to what I'm describing though.
Probably he doesn't stick his
neck out as much as I do. Um, I,
my fundamental argument is that Weber's
distinction between class and status is
a historical distinction.
And this is not accidental that
this is an English speaking person.
Runciman who reads the notion of status,
the way how he reads it.
Because if you know a little German
and you try to read vapor in German,
you know that the word status is actually
a translated from the word she's done
and she's done the val, it can be
translated into English as status,
but it's not very good
translation of the word.
The better translation is a state.
Now,
if you would translate dung as a state,
it would become obvious that
what we is trying to suggest,
that that is something our cake about
status stratification as distinct from
class stratification, which
is a modern phenomenon, right?
So this will be one of the major
points of a time trying to make.
And we will try to show
this, uh, um, uh, uh,
from Viber text. Then,
uh, the question is,
where is the third
dimension? Right? As I said,
a status and class art historical
categories, but valley spower.
Uh,
and when I was working on one of my books,
I was very much attracted to Runciman
Saudia idea and try to interpret vapor and
this way.
And in fact it appeared to me,
agreed deal to use power as
an independent dimension. Um,
uh, uh, uh, uh, the class position. Uh,
I was trying to understand the social
structure of communist societies and their
power appears to be an
independent dimension.
So I was looking into the vapor tax
and I read cover to cover economy and
society a couple of times and I could
not find the term dementia read it.
It is not dead. Uh, um, uh,
so, uh, trying to understand what
FIBA is getting yet. I, you know,
I came to the conclusion that for vapor,
uh,
power is the dependent variable.
What he wants to explain their power
comes from and veterans power exercised is
exercise on the basis of class privileges
or whether it is a state to stype of,
uh, uh, or s state type of power,
which is exercised in society.
And this is very consistent, but you
already knew about Max Faber, right?
Type of authorities
where power comes from.
What legitimate power,
right?
Tradition or legal rational
authority, right? Uh,
class stratification corresponds
to societies based on legal,
rational authority status stratification
corresponds to traditional authority.
All right, well I will, uh,
elaborate a little on this.
Wheel qualified is somewhat
primarily because we were like,
uh, in his, uh, uh, types
of authority as well.
Uh,
has two balls in the air at the same time.
He has a macro theory,
right,
of historical variations
of stratification for him.
Transition From and you know, um, uh,
traditional society in modern rational
societies is a transition from s state
type of stratification
to class stratification.
But vapor also
has a micro theory. He also said, okay,
the society today is
primarily class stratified,
but I can identify status,
power in modern societies as well,
just exactly as he does with
the types of authority. Yes,
the United States today is legal,
rational authority,
but I can spot elements of traditional
authority or Charismatic Authority
operating Visene, legal,
rational authority.
Since it is dominantly legal,
rational authority,
it will be secondary law.
We will make a difference.
But traditional tradition in this society,
in these very America today
does make a difference, right?
It is contract venture
very well in society.
Traditional Authority is consequential,
right?
Uh,
we are all equal before the law,
but in practice where we end up has a lot
to do with traditional tragedy says th
the traditional, they have power
up on age. The same goes for,
he brings back the idea of status.
This is why I've said translating stoned
the status is not completely wrong.
It only gets the footnote
in the vapor concept,
right?
The fourth north is a stunned,
is primarily a historical concept
for past traditional societies.
But by the way,
this is the food note even in contemporary
digital sources out society in class,
that if I societies that is bowed
occasionally exercise on the basis of,
uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, status, uh,
valid.
Obviously,
you know the power which is exercised
by a Supreme Court judge or the power
exercise by a university professor,
the little one we have that
the me probably in some way
try to change your mind,
right? Which is an act of power. Or
some would say even an act of course,
if power,
right.
A booty call the symbolic violence,
right?
I violate your mind.
You know,
if I can penetrate your mind and
put a new idea into your mind,
right?
This is an act of power.
Now it's primarily done
or what grade you done?
Well, I stages, uh,
that you save l this is a professor
who has a phd [inaudible].
Right? Uh, then it is really right.
The reason why you started believing
me has a lot to do with my status.
Hopefully not only the status.
Hopefully I can make a good
argument then past radio,
but occasionally it's a mixture. Now you
tend to believe me or this, believe me.
Right? And the very fact of the status,
what I, uh, what I am incumbent off,
it has something to do,
right? Uh, uh, uh, a few, uh,
trying to believe your professors. So, uh,
uh, let me vary on the notion
how vapor defines classes.
Um,
and the most important issue
is the uniquely they bury
an idea is that class has
to be identified under
Marquette. And then Ivo, uh,
also say a few words about
class interests and how he,
to what extent is different
from marsh in this respect.
So class and market,
uh,
now here you have Themis definitions
and he said class teacher.
And is that your mind by Martha Situation?
Um,
classic tuition is ultimately a market
situation and this is very important.
Now the of as follows,
right?
The effects of nature per session per
is only the fore runner of the our class
formation slaves he's had,
or you can say sheriffs out of not a
class the hour rather as Steve to school.
Now here you can see by the historical
uses of the distinction between class and
status, right? Uh,
and also the challenge to marks a prop,
those who have property and
the private room property, uh,
do not constitute a class.
And the fundamental argument for this
is that in traditional societies,
it is not really property which puts
you into a high status position.
You being in a high status position has
the concept of events that you are of
LC,
right?
So the king or the queen decides to give
you mobility and gives you ns state,
right? Um, in capitalism is
versus the other way around.
In order to become a billionaire,
right?
You don't have to get the approval of
the president of the United States.
Simply enough,
you go to was cheat.
You Invest Your money smartly.
You start with $1,000 and the no
time you have a billion, right?
If you invested it in a smart way
and then you are in the class, right?
Or billionaires,
right?
So here it is your,
your property,
uh,
and your activity on the marketplace,
which end helps you to enter the class,
right?
In the aristocracy, it was
a legal act, right? Uh,
a political act by a king or the Queen,
which made you nobility,
made you are lord.
And then as a construct vents,
you became wealthy, right? It's also
interesting. By the way, that event,
if you lost your valves that were some
poor, noble people, you still repair,
re retained. You are, uh, uh,
status as state privileges.
So if you were mobility in most societies,
for instance,
you did not have to pay taxes.
Now,
if you lost all of your estate, you
know, because you gambled. For instance,
right now you wanted to go to Monte Carlo
or you, you gambled everything, go away,
then you became very bored.
You were a seal Lobel and you still
did not have to write a pay taxes.
Your state status be villages
remained the opposite, right? Uh,
in capitalism you start,
eh,
poorly investing your money and you
lose your money on the stock market,
you cease to be a capitalist, right?
Then you will have to safe to find a job,
right? And since you lost all of your
money, who will not find a very good job?
Because who wants to hire a loser?
Right?
Okay. Uh, uh,
e this is also a very important
citation from vapor. He said, you know,
the class position really means that
people have common life chances,
right? Uh, if, uh,
you are located differently that
are the positively and negatively,
this is the way Berean point positively
or negatively privileged positions on
the market place.
And if you are negatively privileges
privilege in their marketplace,
your life, chances are not
very good, right? If you are
positively privileged, uh,
in the market place than your life,
chances are great.
You guys in this room are Oh,
very positively privileged,
right? Because you are getting
a Yale degree and you know,
probably a Harvard degree would
be even better for you. Uh,
don't tell Rick Levine that I said
that in class, right? Um, but,
uh, um, uh, uh, this is, you
know, about the best degree,
what you can have.
So you are extremely valid positions
on the labor market, right?
Your life chances are great,
right?
You have to make a lot of mistakes
to screw this one, right? Yeah.
Right? You are on the
right trajectory. Um, uh,
if you are in a community college,
right or you are a high school drop out,
then your life chances on the labor
market, we will be lousy. Right? Um,
um, especially you are poor.
You are African American,
you dropped out of high
school. Uh, well, uh,
your chances that you know,
you will end up in jail before
you turn 30 is I think 70%.
Uh, so, right? This is
life chances, right?
Rigid that it in this case of
course, it is not only class, right?
That is a special type of
status group, right? Race.
It also plays a role right in you
that tell you rating life chances.
Now,
let me also say that the,
but actually suggest that you can
think of classes on every single market
situation. Uh, so, uh, for instance,
uh,
some people and I,
myself in my work have been writing
about housing classes that if differences
between the owner of a house and the
tenant who rents this house is at class,
relationship can be interpreted
as a class relationship.
The landlords very often by the
tenants are seen as blessed.
Soccer's right?
Because they charge too high rent and
they do not maintain your unit properly.
You know,
when you call them and,
and you say that the water dripping
and I need a proper, they've,
you'll find excuses why they were
fixed, you know, your uh, uh, uh,
uh, water or by they do
not fix your eating right.
So they are bloodsuckers right?
Uh,
and as a tenant you are in a
negatively privileged class position.
That's true.
But on the other hand,
Labor is quite clear that there are
two important market positions which
fundamentally define your class position.
Um,
and these are the labor market
and in fact the capital market,
uh,
will define where a veteran you are,
have good life chances or poor life
chances and all other positions on other
markets will be consequences
if you position primarily
on the labor market or on
capital markets.
Now this actually brings a
vapor and Mark's a little
closer than it appeared for
the first time, right?
Because as we've, you'll see,
beaver does acknowledge that if there is
a market economy differences in proper,
the are very important to
creating a class positions.
But unlike mark see emphasizes,
this is only the case if that
is a market economy in place.
Now just very briefly about
class interests and class action.
And here he said,
well,
the statement by a talented altar,
he doesn't tell us who that author is.
I assume it must be Karl marks that the
individual may be in error concerning
his interest,
but the class is in a fallible about his
interest is false and pseudoscientific.
So he said, well, the classes
are actually not communities,
right of community may have a kind of
collective understanding that you belong
to a class,
uh,
just because of your position of the
labor market. And you actually hear,
he subscribes to Adam Smith,
right?
Uh,
a class members are individuals acting
out of self interest and not acting out
of collective interests,
but the are in a similar position and
therefore they have common class interests
and surprise, surprise, or occasionally
they will act the same way,
right? Because they have a collective
interest, but not as a community.
But,
uh,
as rationally acting individuals that
share mind by their rational actions,
right on the market place. Uh,
and therefore he said, well,
classes will really exist.
How can I tell that the
class is really exist?
I can tell if I see classes,
acting classes,
Metro allies in action,
right?
Because I speculatively cannot
make any class distinction.
But people VR made distinctions
for classes by acting
upon their class interest.
Now let's go onto the
ration of status groups.
What our status groups and a bell.
I briefly want to identify
who status groups,
our spot status privileges are,
and then a c two stratification, um, uh,
and the cast and question
of ethnicity in Weber's.
So what is the status group?
Well,
unlike classes,
status group or skin there,
this is the pollute
all of the done the uh,
momentally groups. Um, uh,
seaters groups means that
you belong to a group, right?
And you have a high esteem and you
have a solid additive is in the group.
You have an honor.
A certain honor is attribute it to you
when you are in a status group, right?
You are initiated right into becoming a
noble man by an act of the king or the
Queen. Um, uh, well, uh, uh,
in order to get a university degree,
you are initiated right into
a status group. You know,
they do earn a university degree,
a bachelor's degree,
a phd is entering in some
ways as a state role.
It's not accidental that we
were this funny, you know,
medieval robes on those
ceremonies where uh,
the degree is conferred on you and
many professions which require formal
university training act
as a state has growth. Uh,
like the doctors constitute
write a status group like,
uh, uh, in some ways
university professors, uh,
constitute with the status group.
Lawyers constituted a status group and
they somehow control attic sent entrance
into the law profession,
right? Um, uh, the, uh,
you have to pass a board exam if
you want to become a lawyer, right?
And in fact, states three all cause
make, you know, in California,
if you want to move to California,
you want to get a law degree and
you want to move to California,
you'll be a sweat blood,
right to pass the board exam.
If you want to go to South Dakota,
[inaudible] easily passed the board exam
because there are not many lawyers who
want to be lawyers in South Dakota,
but there are many lawyers who want to
be lawyers in San Francisco and therefore
the board,
California board,
we'd be much stricter than the South
Dakota board. The same goes for, uh,
medical eye exams, right? And it would
be, um, again, you have to pass exams.
Um,
and uh,
we will be different depending
on the labor market ocean.
And it's very important.
The C to his honor is best expressed
with specific lifestyle that they,
how you dress, the way how you eat, uh,
the way how you behave is constituting
what is status group traditionally,
right? Mobile men could wear
arms, snow mobiles couldn't. Um,
um, and uh, uh,
well if you are a year professor,
You Vale, uh, j press, right?
Uh, uh, I mean, not everybody
does, but you know, it's, you,
you can tell this is a year.
ProfessorB ,
you can see this as a
cheap j press, um, uh, um,
coat. Uh, so there are
writer, uh, lifestyles. Uh,
um, uh, but in a way,
even in modern society
constitute status groups.
Even with, since class stratification,
you have these uniquely, you know,
lifestyle specific stuff,
but you adapt in order to belong to
these status group kind of subgroup in a
class. So if you are a Yuppie
young, urban professional,
right? You get a nice job on Wall
Street, you move to Manhattan,
right?
Then you rent out,
try it or buy a condo
somewhere in a Trump building,
right?
Then you want to be driven
by a limo to your workplace.
You've, you'll be reading Wall Street
Journal and you will be going, right?
And you'll VOB having crossed
arms for the morning, right?
And you'll see what I'm getting
yet, right? Yeah. You'll be,
you'll be dressed in a certain
way. People can tell, right,
this person must be a broker.
Right? On Wall Street,
there are these lifestyle characteristics,
but in a way creates
an almost status group.
You know each other, right? You
recognize each other, right?
There are places where you hang
together, right? There are Erp places.
You look outside and you know,
this is a Yuppie Brown field with grps.
This is the lifestyle
and by this shoe as them.
And that also of course
status privileges, um, uh,
which is ideal and material goods,
which is the consequence of you being
in that status group read or uh,
uh, then, uh, the source of it. Uh,
and there are also specific
special employment opportunities.
If you belong to a status group
and it's being controlled way.
I mean, adequate profession
is a very good example.
It's being actually the Beatty.
Then questions,
why on earth do we need a system in
which people have to have registered,
you know, do have to have a medical degree
in order to practice medicine, right?
Uh,
why owners,
people who have to have a law degree in
order to appear in court and the fence,
somebody in court, right? These are
kind of status grew up, uh, uh, uh,
uh, barriers to enter, uh, uh, the sister.
Well,
the market on the other hand knows
no personal distinction. Well,
under market it matters whether you are
successful or you are a failure, right?
And therefore, if you have the
status group kind of privileges,
this is a limitation on the
functioning of the market, right?
And therefore stronger
the status groups are,
if he can be a hindrance of free
development of a market economy.
And now an idea about the
Kras and that necessity.
He said if the boundaries
between car, uh, uh,
status groups are particularly sharp
re drone in that case we can talk about
casts the caste differences occur.
For instance,
when that APP low emissions to
intermarry between cast a lower cash,
I'll usually seen as polluted as dirty.
You even cannot touch them.
Or if you ha you did
touch a low class person,
let's say an Indian culture,
you have to go some purification
procedures. Uh, right.
Uh, and he said, uh,
status group segregation grows into cast.
That dance forms a horizontal coexistence
of ethnically segregated groups into a
vertical social system. Uh, uh,
this is also very important, right? His
notion of ethnicity. It's a very, uh,
very innovative idea in writing
this around 1920 about this I,
the,
the differences are held to be ethnic
on based on the belief that it has
something to do with blood relations,
right? He does not believe,
right,
that ethnic differences really have
anything to do with the blood relations.
You have ethnical racial differences,
then that is a common belief that blood
relations do matter and are socially
construct venture.
He doesn't believe it is now
class and status compared,
uh, um, uh, I, um, sort of
running out of time drawn from to,
uh,
operate on to do too much on this. Uh, uh,
the, the point right that, uh,
uh, uh, uh, um,
that is some kind of stability in state
to stratification a class certification
is dynamic and,
and conflict shores.
This is where his idea of your
come from that in fact, uh, uh, um,
uh,
class relationships are not becoming
more antagonistic over time,
but it's becoming less antagonistic
over time. But the point is,
as you can see that the main point is
that there are two basic stratification
system, one based on uh, uh,
status or Shonda. And
the other one is a, um,
class stratification
historical difference.
But that is also a type of stratification
in a class stratified society based on
status differences.
So what are he makes a distinction
between different types of classes.
Let me just briefly how, Gosh through
off it. He does not negate that.
That is actually a class based on property
that is actually the property differences
can be very substantial as long as the
upper think in a market place.
If you know your property
can be sold or bought,
which was not the case under feudalism.
And if that is a labor market
which complements capital markets,
then differences in capital
markets is the source of, uh, uh,
differences. Uh, um, um, uh,
but the most important distinction
is what he calls commercial classes.
And commercial classes are based
right on the market situation,
um, and particularly, uh,
specially based on labor markets.
And therefore the Basic Class Distinction
for vapor in modern society is between
management and employees
rather than owners of Capitol
and owners of labor power
online marks. And that I think is, uh, uh,
very insightful argument,
at least an important, uh,
uh,
qualification on marsh are probably a
used for replacement of marks with a
better fitting theory to
understand modern societies.
Okay. Uh, and then that are,
he introduces the notion of social
classes that is a type of class in modern
society,
which is social class and social class
people out in a social class situation.
Then individual and
generational mobility is easy.
And typically we see in that class.
Uh,
and then he said, well, what are
social classes? And interestingly,
he said, well, these as examples
are working class is a social class.
The petty bourgeoisie is a social class.
The basic argument here
is that, uh, you know,
working class is not a commercial class
working class or valleys writing 19th
century, but it's, this is
still to some extent true, uh,
in the United States today, probably
the least. So in the u s uh,
than in other economies.
Then, you know, um, uh,
being working class was certainly
very true in Europe. Um, uh,
probably less so now,
but even during the second half of
the 20th century in Italy and France,
that it was a very strong
working class consciousness.
You are proud of being working class in
the u s the term working class hardly
exist,
right?
We are talking about the working
people rather than a hurricane class,
but in Italy or in France where it's a
very strong identity of being a working
class, very clearly
identifiable lifestyle features.
Now that if in fact in the United States
you can't really, you usually can tell,
I think with 90% certainty
if you walk into a tavern,
right? Um, or you know who,
who is a manual work and who is
not a manual very care, right?
The way how people behave,
the way how people dress,
it gives you a very good clue.
And you know,
in France or in Italy to some extent,
even in the United States, uh, you know,
working class, if you'll say, well,
it was good enough for me to be plumper.
Why owners?
My son doesn't want to be a plumper
and continue my business as a plumber.
That's good enough. Right?
If it was good enough for me,
it should be good enough for
my son and other, you know,
how he understands the social class as a,
as distinct from economic class.
You become a social class when you say,
well you are in working class and uh,
uh,
your daughter is dating a lawyer.
He will say, can't you find a
decent working class guy? Uh,
you want to date with this ache had again,
in the United States it is
much less common, right?
That is many more metro mobility
across class lines, much less so,
uh, in Italy, uh, or uh, or
in France even, even today.
Uh, anyway, this is social class. But
as you can see social class in a way,
bringing back the idea of status groups.
It is a modern version of status group,
but is being constituted as a social
class cause it has a lot to do bit
lifestyles, values, culture, right?
And typical patterns of mobility
and the aspirations. Um,
uh, such bell, that's about it.
Thank you very much.